[Music]
on the surface and even at a fundamental
level destiny too is a lot more destiny
the structure is largely the same as is
the mechanically excellent shooting and
satisfying loot grind there are a
variety of changes both under the hood
and throughout your activities that make
it a significant improvement over the
original and a better experience for
more than just the most hardcore players
[Music]
from the onset there's an overwhelming
amount of stuff to do the red war story
funnels you through each of the four
areas you can explore introducing you to
each one as you go at each destination
there's a bunch of optional activities
to choose from including story like
adventure missions simple loop dungeons
called lost sectors that lead to hidden
areas of the map and public events and
controls which return from destiny one
then as you progress through the story
you'll unlock the strike playlist and
PvP in the crucible for a newcomer to
destiny it can be hard to know what to
do and when there are a lot more
survivors out there and they need our
help we got to get the word out that the
farm is a safe haven I sent a friend
into the EDC a few hours ago to set up a
comm networking
his name's Debra McKay good guy great
shot don't tell him I said that
the story missions are less about plot
and more about acclimating you to
everything there is to see you'll level
up at a pretty steady pace but there are
two level gated missions that
essentially force you to complete
adventures and other activities for XP
before you can move on there's no actual
reason for the missions to have level
requirements which can be a bit annoying
but having direction is welcome after
destiny ones lack thereof and aside from
adding new XP and loot the semi hidden
loss sectors reward exploration while
adventures are filled with lore and
interesting details about the world that
fall outside of the scope of the main
story plus if you're burnt out on
standard PvE you can switch to PvP to
level up which requires different gear
and skills
the Red Horse story isn't enough to
serve its main purpose which is to
contextualize the shooting and looting
you're doing through it all you don't
need to know much to get going except
that humanity is in danger and you of
all people have the power to help the
story strengths lie in atmosphere inside
details not plot and that should be fine
for the majority of players who see the
story as a prerequisite to playing the
actual game the mournful soundtrack in
particular is fantastic and that's what
carried me through the most basic story
beats even on repeat playthroughs it's a
hell of a view isn't it why can destiny
one there's a lot of grinding to be done
between finishing the story and moving
on to the high level endgame activities
like the nightfall strike and the raid
and again like in destiny 1 the shoot
and loot feedback loop feels fantastic
the gunplay is still excellent and being
rewarded for your efforts with an even
better gun is something we're
celebrating the biggest change is how
much quicker it is to increase your
light level now called power with
minimal grinding early on the combat
isn't any easier because of it though so
it simply takes away the destiny one ERA
frustration of running the same few
strikes a dozen times before you can
move on to literally anything else plus
knowing you might get a slightly more
fashionable pair of gauntlets from a
five-minute public event gives you the
kind of instant gratification that will
sustain you through to the end game
though there's plenty you can do on your
own destiny to is undeniably a shared
experience that can come on many
different levels you can work silently
with complete strangers to trigger a
heroic public event that gets you all
better loot and on the opposite end of
the spectrum you can coordinate with
five friends for hours on end to tackle
the raid you can also join a clan which
can grant you a number of passive
benefits like legendary gear as long as
someone in your clan is meeting certain
milestones on top of that destiny 2 also
introduces guided games where solo
players can search for groups who are
short one person and willing to help
them through difficult in-game
activities like the nightfall or raid
success through strong teamwork is
absolutely the best part of destiny in
the top to bottom tweaks and additions
in destiny 2 can make it more accessible
without dampening your sense of
accomplishment meeting the level
requirement for the nightfall or raid
and actually completing it are two very
different things and getting in sync
with your fireteam and swallow
the executing a strategy takes a lot of
work the first two nightfall strikes for
example both introduced a modifier to
the original strike that forces you and
your team to coordinate load outs and
stay in constant communication about
which weapons and subclasses you're
using you have to figure that out while
also shooting waves of enemies and
trying not to die you'll most likely
fail but each failure helps you perfect
your strategy incrementally and the
process of collectively achieving that
goal is immensely satisfying
this versus seven
let's enjoy ourselves at the highest
level the vast and visually striking
raid combines the need for top-tier
weapons and gear picking the correct
subclass and loadout based on what your
team needs strong combat skills and
problem-solving as a group destiny
choose first raid Leviathan is very very
difficult and solving its often obscure
puzzles can be both rewarding and
frustrating for the most part each
failure teaches you something new and
the GameSpot raid team actually cheered
after we came up with a solid strategy
while going in blind
but there was one section in the middle
that we struggled to complete even after
we figured out what to do conceptually
of course this was after about five
straight hours of raiding so fatigue was
definitely a factor but it didn't blend
the puzzle solving part with actual
execution as well as the previous
sections of the raid did in true destiny
fashion if you do something once you'll
probably end up doing it many more times
the difference with destiny 2 is in the
variety and accessibility of what's
available which cuts down on a lot of
the frustration associated with grinding
and even after you've leveled up there's
still more you can do from Keeping Up
with daily and weekly challenges to just
hanging out with friends it's a much
stronger foundation in the original had
and one that's enough on its own to keep
people coming back week after week if we
wait we die but if we attack together we
can take back our home our light our
hope or we die trying
No
I need my fire team I need my Korra and
Kate
[Music]